RESPOND TO REQUEST FOR COMMENT
ON THIS MULTISTATE LAWSUIT.
THE RESTAURANT WHOSE OWNER SAID
THE PRESIDENT ASKED THE PRESS
SECRETARY TO LEAVE OVER THE
WEEKEND WILL REMAIN CLOSED FOR
SEVERAL MORE DAYS.
THAT OWNER HAS ALSO NOW JUST
RESIGNED FROM A LOCAL BUSINESS
ORGANIZATION THERE.
MEANWHILE, MANY IN THE SMALL
NORTHERN VIRGINIA COMMUNITY FEAR
THEIR BUSINESS MAY NOW SUFFER.
LEXINGTON VIRGINIA, REMIND US
THAT SOME CIVIL WARS ARE NOT AS
SOFT AS THE ONE LEXINGTON IS
EXPERIENCING TODAY.
NUMEROUS SHOP OWNERS REFUSED TO
TALK TO US ABOUT THE REDHEAD IN
CONTROVERSY, WORRIED THAT IF YOU
TAKE ASIDE YOU RISK ALIENATING
HALF YOUR CUSTOMERS.
>> IT'S VERY PAINFUL FOR ME
ARE MOUTHING OFF ON EITHER SIDE.
>> I HOPE YOU ARE NOT ONLY
TALKING TO PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT
THIS.
WHAT SHE DID IS REALLY AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO ALL OF US.
>> THE REDHEAD OWNER WAS ALSO
UNTIL TODAY THE EXECUTIVE CHAIR
OF AN INFLUENTIAL BUSINESS GROUP
TODAY.
SHE RESIGNED FROM THAT POST THIS
AFTERNOON ACCORDING TO PUBLISHED
REPORTS.
>> AFTER SARAH AND HER HUSBAND
LEFT AND THE FAMILY RELOCATED
THE OWNER OF THE RED HEN THEN
ORGANIZED AN EFFORT TO GO AND
SCREAM AT THEM FROM THE SIDEWALK
AT THE OTHER RESTAURANT.
>> HIS STORY CONFIRMED BY THE
MAN WHO HOSTED THE SANDERS
FAMILY AT HIS BED AND BREAKFAST.
>> IT'S AN UNFORTUNATE SITUATION
BECAUSE I GUESS, AGAIN, IF YOU
ARE TO MAKE A STATEMENT, MAKE
THE STATEMENT, DON'T KEEP
SCREAMING AT AND FOLLOW PEOPLE
OR WHAT HAVE YOU.
>> 200 MILES TO THE NORTH THE
CONGRESSMAN WHO WAS NEARLY
KILLED BY THE GOVERNMENT WITH
EXTREMIST VIEWS KNOWS HOW FAR
SUCH INCIVILITY CAN GO.
>> I KNOW FIRSTHAND.
WE'VE GOT TO BE REAL CAREFUL
ABOUT HOW WE DISCUSS OUR
DIFFERENCES.
THE GREAT PART OF AMERICA IS
THAT WE CAN DISCUSS OUR
DIFFERENCES FREELY AND OPENLY
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF WE ARE NOT TRYING TO INCITE
OTHERS TO VIOLENCE.
>> MORE DEMOCRATS ARE JOINING
THE CALL FOR CIVILITY.
A SPOKESMAN FOR VIRGINIA
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR TIM KAINE
TOLD THE RICHMOND TIMES THAT HE
"BELIEVES IN CIVILITY AND
RESPECT FROM EVERYONE ARE
IMPORTANT TO A FUNCTIONING
DEMOCRACY."
>> WE ARE TOLD AT THE RED HEN
AFTERNOON WILL NOW REMAIN CLOSED
UNTIL JULY 5TH.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME AS YOU
THEY ARE WINDING DOWN RIGHT NOW.
ONLY ONE ARREST THUS FAR, A
DONALD TRUMP SUPPORTER THROUGH A